vera le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a déclaré que la russie était
prête à rompre les relations avec
l'union européenne est ce que vous avez
plus de précisions bonjour grégory oui
effectivement la russie est prête à une
rupture des relations avec l'union
européenne c'est ce qu'a déclaré le chef
de la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
dans une interview à une chaîne youtube
sur le viol live le ministre a quand
même souligné que la russie ne voudrais
pas s'isoler de la vie mondiale je vous
propose donc d'écouter un extrait de son
intervention sur le seuil osons nous
partons du principe que nous y sommes
prêts au cas où nous verrons une fois de
plus comme nous l'avons déjà ressenti
crois que dans certains domaines des
sanctions et aux frais des risques pour
notre école de musique heures y compris
dans les domaines les plus sensibles
sont imposés ce week-end
nous ne voulons pas nous isoler de la
vie mondiale ils devront être prêts le
nom de nom si vous voulez la paix pour
préparer la guerre cette déclaration de
sergueï lavrov intervient une semaine
après la visite à moscou du chef de la
diplomatie européenne josette borel
ce dernier a fait savoir via son porte
parole que l'union européenne était en
train de préparer de nouvelles sanctions
à l'égard de la russie mais ce travail
porte à un caractère confidentiel
les relations entre la russie et le eux
sont pour reprendre les paroles de josep
borrell au plus bas à cause de la
situation en ukraine en biélorussie et
mais aussi au fait de l'arrestation de
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni et
détention de plusieurs manifestants lors
d'un rassemblement non autorisé le 23 et
le 31 janvier en russie merci verhaeghe
hoffman pour toutes ces précisions en
direct de moscou en russie